so this talk being just half an hour
sorry I'm repeating myself for those who
have been here before
is obviously it's a high-level
presentation about what you can do with
JavaScript in and machine learning and
what libraries are out there and what
you know can't leverage that trying to
overcome so there are things that you
can do in JavaScript right now with pure
JavaScript first you can do cat
recognition for those who like cats so
I'm just showing you up insert hopefully
it will work here we go and oh it
finally cut in the middle of the picture
I don't know if you so you can do
digital recognition which is a classic
machine learning example so he am gonna
draw seven will roughly recognized up
it's recognized here it's rubbish
obviously my handwriting is horrible but
yeah other interesting applications so
self-driving car simulations obviously
you know Tesla being in the media and
stuff but there is the MIT did a course
on self-driving cars and and so there
was stir-frying
Tesla and to simulate how you know you
need to recognize or adjust parameters
they have done this simulation which is
on top of famous JavaScript framework or
conf net GS and basically you can model
your white car and see how it goes and
first you can go so in my presentation I
have all the links that you need if you
want to experience these libraries image
manipulation so to file here lighthouse
and you can see how fast it fast it is
to actually manipulate the data so
greyscale the picture draw the edges
flip top which I'll resize it zoom it
actually zoom then flipped actually what
you can do you know for developers
that's interesting the automatic local
generator so I'm gonna try to do add
live so can GS and if you go down you
will see they it generates different
types of logos like you know just
improve your crotch video and you know
arrows to your creativity the other
thing you machine learning you not only
work with numbers you can work with
words as well so classic example of spam
filters and email filtering oh you know
when you work when you have sorry on
your iphone or search boxes it's all
about what position so it's called
natural language processing and there is
also this project that I found out on
and on github recently it's a I for
robots of photos think Jessica we talked
about sensor and Anna was talking about
out windows so this combines you know
artificial intelligence and Arduino and
ro
so you kind of have fun with everything
and all in node.js and note very high
level I try to expose the key concepts
of machine so we oppose supervised to
unsupervised machine learning so
supervised is when you you have a
specific set of inputs and you know you
output you know what to expect at the
end of the day so you're trying to find
a function if you want that will map all
the X variables to the targeted output Y
so to pick your two types like
classification when it's a discrete set
of outputs so check if you are you know
let's say you have a set of colors so
you categorize whether blue or your
emails if it's spam or not spam its
classification problems then you have
regular regression problems so
regression is when the output variable
is continuous so it can be in dollars or
weights for instance if you think of L
say you wanted to do a study on property
prices and you think of well what's
what's the location what's the square
footage on number of rooms you know does
it have a garage or swimming pool all
those features and you try to have it
you know today how much your property
would be worse so that's kind of
regression problem so examples of
algorithms that suppose that is linear
regression support vector machines and
random forest random forest is like a
tree and basically you do multiple trees
or randomly you set up the parameters
randomly so that's why we call it random
forests unsupervised learning is when
you don't actually
know the output you want actually to
discover the different groupings and
different classifications out of the
blue so you have clustering problems and
Association problems so clustering given
a certain set of data it's used for
instance in in the medical world like if
you have a certain set of features your
sex your age your you know health habits
how how and or in biology in general
like if you have a certain set of
features and you groups and what type of
disease or what type of plants you come
to associations is to discover the wars
among this data so really at the high
level it's supervised versus
unsupervised so that's a classic
description of neural network which is
one of the main algorithm in machine
learning so you have a set of inputs so
as I said before for instance in the
real estate example the square footage
the number of rooms sets your input
layer so you have a number as a number
of inputs as a number of features and
the output so here you have two
different outputs it could be spam not
spam it could be just one output but a
price you have not put layer and in
between the output and out sorry
in between the input and the output
layers you can have hidden layers and
there can be like it can be from one to
n number of layers depending on the
contract and complexity and here it is
where it's mod an art and a science to
decide which
of hidden layers our network but this
might not appear to everybody in terms
of understanding of a neural network I
find sometimes it's easier to have this
kind of representation like a typical
tabular representation so the features
you know from you can see in terms of
widths of the data set and the number of
examples like the height of X in that
example and so it's obviously it's it
looks like a matrix and you try to
arrive ads for each example you know
which output you're gonna get so it's
you try to approximate why the column
one to the next to the matrix so you're
trying to find out the function or the
weights that you apply to the your data
set the X and this approximation gives
you a score the Y hat which is you know
what outputs given a current model so in
mathematical terms it would be just it's
f of X gives you Y and you try to
minimize Y hat compared to Hawaii I
don't know if it makes sense to
everybody
yes
this one is looks easier for you but it
may be the second representation makes
you more I understand that you know you
have all this number of examples the
output that you expect why and we are
trying the game is ready to try to
minimize why and why heart okay and we
are and to basically to do that you
adjust you to you you adjust the W which
are the weights that you apply to the
number of features y hat it's basically
the result of your model of W times X if
you want the different weights that you
apply to your data set so basically this
thing called perceptron is just one part
of let's say
[Music]
so the in terms of calculations if you
apply to you inputs
different weights you sum them like in a
multi linear regression and you activate
them mixing them like you know binary is
it zero or one do you accept it in your
model or not
and so this perceptron is also hidden
layers and the output layers are
calculated in that manner you apply a
different set of weights between the
input and the hidden layers and a
different set of weights between hidden
layer and output layer and you at the
end of the day you try to compare the
output layer to the calculations from
your weights and the different layers to
the output layer and you try to minimize
this error between what you've
calculated and what is actual does it
make sense so another key concept and it
was discovered relatively recently
recently in that case means in the last
15 years is the concept of back
propagation so you can do these
calculations about weights in one way
but really for it to improve and so it's
that the network learns you have this
concept of back propagation so that you
you back up the error that you found out
at the way that you calculate
the between the calculated output and
the real output you try to integrate it
backwards into the weights into the
weight down between the even an output
layer and between the input and hidden
layer so how so you integrate the error
and it's a iterative process and here
you your errors close to zero was as
close to zero as possible and that can
be done basically thanks to because we
all know the properties of the
activation functions so this is possible
to to go backwards or to back propagate
your error thanks to the directives so
activation these are examples of
activation functions so I really you
have to think of activate sham factions
as trying to squeeze a number
[Music]
and I don't know if you have a
correction from when you are doing
algebra and maybe in high school or
encouraged when you want so most cost
functions have a convex feature okay
and so you know what convex is like it
looks like like a you basically and when
you want to minimize so to go to the
button to find the local minimum on on
the convex function you use a direct
innovative and try to go to the zero
basically so you use a slope of the
curve in a convex function to try to
reach the minimum as a local minimum so
that says how we achieve back
propagation and that's how we can
achieve the whole iterative process of
improvement so you calculate a certain
output you calculate the cost error and
back propagated into the weights and you
and then you there is a learning rate
which makes it improve every time so
these are the classic cost functions
most I guess but you have a number of
different types of trails okay enough
mass for today though so obviously all
these calculations you know at the end
of the day
you need performance from your computer
to to realize this and the browser
obviously is not the the lowest level
you can do your calculations and most
libraries would be in C++ I don't think
they're in any assembly to my knowledge
but there would be in in a very in much
more low level language however when you
handle calculations it's often done in
Python and Python is just a wrapper
around these C++ libraries that being
said if we were just doing Python verses
JavaScript performance comparisons most
of the time javascript with the
improvements of the v8 engine and you
know the different browser engines it's
actually faster than Python it's just
that when you do deep learning networks
that when you do like image recognition
and not just of cats because here it was
a bit cheating the cat was recognized
because we could find two ears like you
know the sign of so that was a shortcut
but if you want to did at a production
level like you know Google size you need
really like a lot of GPUs to do that and
why GPU is because coming from the
gaming world that's where most
calculations for refreshing screens
come from and so they are very much used
to all the vectors and matrix
calculations that are actually used in
machine learning so the leader in this
in that field is Nvidia or when you have
NVIDIA GPU card they have actually also
created libraries that enable you
advanced mathematical operations so in
the JavaScript world we are used to the
simplest way to do that is array of
arrays but it's actually not the most
performing a way to do that for
accessing a particular item you would do
what you know given the matrix a and
aware of arise you you access your
elements by you know I mean a J which
you know I'm sure everybody would be
able to do but it's not if you want to
iterate over that or access or transpose
or these matrix it it won't be very fast
one faster way to do that is to use
typed arrays which is my second example
and it's faster but the thing is he is
he you can see so one so it's very fast
using typed arrays but to access the
different elements when you want to do
higher order operations is is a bit
cumbersome so there is a compromise
where this index the three in my example
here is actually it's the sorry it's a
general linear function so here
so here you can really switch rows and
columns very quickly you can transpose
numbers in the matrix much quicker and
there has been a library that has used
this idea of straight arrows and which
is ngrs it's used in a number of low
level and high level libraries named GS
which is a kind of vampire for those who
are familiar with Python that tries to
use the same kind of functions that
numpy or matlab have has Chara's takes
the name of a famous library which is a
higher-order library a higher level
library on top of tensorflow
or Tiano which are more lower level or
matrix calculations so Karis it would be
easier to do artificial neural network
recurrent neural network it's it's good
for prototyping machine learning models
the only thing the Charis javascript
model you can only in a way to forward
propagation you can only do what's
called inference and not back
propagation so the training of you
models won't be done in JavaScript it
would be done in in Python and then once
you have your model you use JavaScript
to visualize these things so tensile
fire is the latest library it uses in
their eyes but it also uses WebGL under
the hood so other ways to do
calculations in on the CPU is using web
assembly there are fewer examples of
that and there are less mature
but it's certainly avenues to explore to
improve the speed of calculations on the
CPU and also to increase the the
parallelism of calculations in browsers
you can use service workers that being
said there is a cost of transferring
your data from your brother straight to
the service workers and back so there
will be a slight delay compared to pure
CPU so as I mentioned you can do
calculations leveraging your CPU or you
can leverage WebGL so a number of
libraries have emerged and the latest
won't be intense a fire which was so
that on Twitter like two weeks ago so
it's really recent but they haven't for
the moment open source that code so as I
said I found a npm library by the Queen
from github basically it leverages JSL
so the language that is used with WebGL
you can use also leverage new GPU
differently using opens here or web GPU
but then I guess it's not it will be a
different setup it will be using a node
wasn't purely the browser and usually
it's you can it's restricted to a
certain number of projects it's not
cross browser compatible right so that
was my high level in terms of concepts
from machine learning I want you to
explore a number of blogs and libraries
that you can use in JavaScript or
courses if you are interested in the air
so this chamber didn't all plug in
machine learning addressing not neural
network but a lot of unsupervised
learning algorithm and the second one is
that I mentioned here
Andre capaci is is quite interesting
because this guy is relatively famous he
developed one of the first deep learning
library in JavaScript called Canet Jia's
to do convolutional neural networks on
pictures and he's he used to work for so
he's from Stanford and he used to do
work for open and I and recently he has
been he has been hired by Tesla to
improve machine learning for cars so the
a number of JavaScript specific
resources so contact us and
unfortunately is no longer maintained
tensorflow you have a nice tensorflow
playground to play with which is here
you can add a number of hidden layers
different features and you can so it's
nice to play around in terms of what you
can achieve and how long it takes to to
improve your model so it's tensorflow
playing around so it's it's a really
it's written in typescript and it's only
a very small set of the tensorflow
library do you know actually - do people
understand what a tensor is by any
chance no okay so you should think of
tensor as a container like a number of
scalar would be a tensor of of size zero
a vector so I'm gonna go to so a vector
would be a tensor of one dimension
a matrix with rows and columns would be
a tensor of two dimensions and a cube so
three dimensions would be a tensor flow
a tensor of three dimensions so it's you
have to think of it as a container so
libraries and if if you are more
interested so you can get involved at
different levels maybe some like to go
into the lower levels of the matrix and
vector calculations or you can go higher
level and talk about different types of
architecture and convert yes and more
recently this one optic which tries to
do neuro evolution so neuro evolution
for those who don't know it's it's kind
of it tries to it's a generation of
genetic algorithm which means that they
let's say you can to randomly generate a
number of of examples and basically you
you try to the you try to eliminate
those who don't work as much so it's
it's a very Darwinian process in the way
you generate a number of of examples you
you keep the ones who survive the
longest then you regenerate a number of
set of examples and and and so forth
breaking so so there has been a number
of universities involved in to do
machine learning in JavaScript one would
I would say is more on the edges from
the University of Tokyo Marg yes they do
libraries which are relatively very
Japanese friendly like sushi to tempura
sukiyaki
but they have like sushi - is for
instance for matrix calculation sukiyaki
is for on top of sushi - to do different
machine learning models they do
distributed computing so they have
created a framework where you have
different browsers and basically you
leverage the capabilities from you know
maybe using web sockets so you can
connect different computers different
browsers and you leverage the CPUs of
these different browsers you have to
once with new versity which the other
two universities are maybe less
no no less marketed in a way I had
really learned just by chance that they
existed and they have actually quite a
few libraries on NPM on github the last
one actually doesn't have a npm but he
does have a github i asked them if you
wanted to leverage NPN but the guidance
is a point of using javascript was not
yes I don't know that's this point but
as I have a nice online laboratory where
you can actually download some files and
you can you know use most common machine
learning libraries on it to you know try
to create a model Coursera I personally
so I'm not an expert in the field I am
still doing it actually
I recommend the Coursera course from
from under Angie who is who used to work
at Google and and Baidu he was a chief
machine learning or chief artificial
intelligence guy from Baidu so the
Chinese company Geoffrey Hinton
so his course on neural networks in
Corsa Geoffrey Hinton is one of the
leaders in machine learning and it's
quite unique that you can find his you
know cause from him completely free on
Coursera Udacity proposes a number of of
nano degrees in the field the examples
that I showed you on deep traffic the
mighty cause a lot of people from the
start idea engineer were involved in
that so I don't have networks so
unfortunately on behavior but basically
they participated in in this in this set
up as well there are lots of resources
on the internet blogs which are not most
of the time not JavaScript specific so
JavaScript ones have these ones that I
mentioned yes so you can get involved
also to encourage getting involved there
is a a I grant where for whatever
projects and tents of fire the latest
library that I mentioned they
participated in the AI grant competition
and they won 5,000 from that to when
they created tens a file or cackle
cackle a Chinese was co-founded by an
Australian guy and it's a it's a website
where people can do machine learning
competitions and and there are open
design sets and there is a forum when
you share your tips and tricks to
improve the accuracy of your models so
as I was very fast and you know involved
but if you have any questions probably
sorry yes sure yeah I will put this yes
yes Oh tons of fire I think you can try
the demos that I have on your mobile I
personally don't know you know the ones
compressions for that I the one of the
thing is I guess the calculations would
be I mean I don't think you GPU on the
robot is in terms of tower it is great
that point so I don't think you know I
mean if we're improve a bit in a while
because it's paralyzed so it's you know
in parallel to your CPU by in terms of
pure raw performance I don't think it's
right that being said I know that Google
with tensorflow has tried to you know I
mean democratize the use of its library
and so I encourage it since i do android
apps on that but i personally haven't
tested it so
[Laughter]
so the way yeah but these tend to
multiply each feature so one dimension
right and then so so first you do one
thing we generate these waves so then
you use X as a technicians so summer
like the matrix calculations but then
you actually I'm using one of the
functions that showed you before and you
do that for every neuron every layer and
gives you Y hat see what comes from your
words okay so then you try to calculate
cost you have cosmetics or the most
famous ones meets quite happy y Y minus
y hat square
okay so once you have that measure of
terror
okay you you back propagate this peril
into thanks to the derivatives of the
activation functions back to the initial
input okay so it changed and then it's
an interactive process for the numerical
example or coding example if you want
like this mobile like linear regression
with the senate hungary like competitive
tenses like the number of my sweat
combinations that you could work them
over is it just for like the to do I
mentioned problem anything off about the
error right so actually the fact that
you have hidden layers and you have so
it improves if you want the
non-linearity of your form so let me
show you what I mean
so you're thinking of given us a set
like that you can see it's not very well
just doing mineral regression it would
be a straight line okay so if you were
doing just input outputs that's what you
would expect it's a linear regression
but the fact that you implement a hidden
layer in the middle deep improves the
non-linearity of your of your models so
I have done that example in JavaScript
so just rajasic regression and just
input output without hidden layers will
give you a straight line okay but if you
had hidden layer and I said I mean here
the core is entitled but I've done the
same in JavaScript you the fact that you
introduce an inland then with time you
know so you can see
you can see you you add a non-linearity
to your problem so and the more you add
basically the more precise in your
non-linearity you can go okay so then
it's a complexity then there is you want
to go over that but you can over fit
your data so then in terms of if you
want to predict you know so with your
model you have to be very careful that
it doesn't offer that you mother does an
overfit you test data
obviously that's numerical complexities
I I don't have the exact answer but you
know it's it's adding a row it's
basically adding a few matrices to your
to your calculation so in terms of I
know computer scientists calculate in
terms of or something it would be at
least mean square added square capacity
any other question
you